A real-life Batman has been spotted in Japan.
We've heard of Batman superfans...
...but one individual in Japan is taking their fandom to a whole new level.
The Dark Knight impersonator was recently spotted speeding down the highway...
...wearing all the Bat gear while riding their very own Batcycle.
From the mask to the suit, to the belt and the shoes,...
...this Batman's Bat duds look pretty legit.
After reportedly being spotted outside of the city of Chiba,...
...Japan's Caped Crusader copycat has apparently earned the nickname "Chibatman."
But despite the resemblance to the Batman in the movies,...
...it's clear that Chibatman's superhero powers are much more limited...
...because like the rest of us, he is no match against the forces of traffic.